[Música]
a oi estava esperando que bom que você
veio está preparado pra mim é uma
experiência única
eu vou ser um pedaleiro guia bounahra o
trajeto para você você os seus olhos
aqui está nossa bicicleta que tal
redonda ao swing e no já vamos voar
vamos decolar
11 23 já começou
então essa correria do dia a dia com
tanta informação quanto tempo o são
paulo prometeu coração se lembra que só
em que você tinha de fazer tudo que você
sempre queijo
tá rolando que está acontecendo eu estou
vendo aqui é meu amigo aquele negócio
que estava estressada dão que você achou
que não ia fechar aqui na tua frente à
fechado deu certo cara tá tudo dando
certo
o cara tá vendo você com a família tá
brincando com seus filhos e tem tempo
pra eles
pegando no cursinho na escola
participando da esposa o marido dela
está boa
você faz o que você quer trabalhar com
que você quer ganhar dinheiro
você está em paz meu amigo nunca deixe
de se amar esqueça nunca diz preparado
agora a guerra está acabando
tira venda pode tirar sem pressa
agora vou representar o sol ouro sou
cego há seis anos e resolver e na minha
impossível não é um fato impossível só
uma opinião eu tenho feito isso busquei
feliz
eu queria que você se você acredita
você pode mudar sua vida vai na sua afaa
agora é com você
o dia
todo mundo acordou quem dormia não né
tudo bem felicidade pra mim tá aqui com
vocês seja um fazendo é o que significa
esse essa instituição para mim foi onde
eu comecei minha vida profissional é eu
tenho amor pela union que sejam fazem
idéia pessoa unison a decoração é
possível que eu chore aqui um pouquinho
eu sou muito criticado as palestras
corporativas que eu dou porque meu
coração grita e aí eu vou lá e chora
porque minha mãe tá ali também eu sou um
pouco e xororó
mas é o que eu acho que eu fiz aqui foi
tirar um pouquinho do que de uma frase
que estava inscrita num convite que
recebeu para a palestra punk é o
seguinte o mundo que você enxerga mas
principalmente que você quer enxergar o
que você quer fazer dele
essa é uma coisa importante a gente
adicionou uma frase a essa essa situação
é a seguinte viveu o melhor da vida é
uma decisão única e exclusivamente sua
viver o melhor da vida é uma decisão
única e exclusivamente sua
bom é o que vocês viveram agora com o
álvaro no ano na verdade é exatamente o
que a obra deseja pra vocês uma vida boa
vida plena é ea gente tá falando aqui de
todo mundo de gente muito bem preparada
de gente não tão bem preparado gente tem
muito dinheiro gente que não tem tanto
dinheiro o que li o que ele contou pra
vocês aqui é o que a gente vive no
projeto pedaleiros nosso dia do projeto
pedaleiros esse projeto é um projeto que
surgiu no dia em que eu tomei a decisão
de tomar posse da minha vida pra mim e
ficar perto do amigo perto de mim bem
perto é de mim e aí eu criei um projeto
de liberdade pra mim é o chamado novo
traço que a empresa não traz ué é a
empresa dos meus sonhos da empresa que
eu gostaria de trabalhar eu queria fazer
os meus horários eu queria trabalhar com
os clientes que eu desejava para fazer o
que eu queria é um tópico mas eu
conseguir
sim é o que eu faço 11 anos e eu faço
isso com muito amor e eu queria que essa
empresa não fosse boa pra mim que ela
fosse boa para todo mundo
as pessoas que trabalham comigo então o
dinheiro que ali se chama tiago que eu
sou completamente apaixonado por esse
cara porque ele é um menino que está
comigo há muito tempo virou meu sócio e
eu descobri que realmente a gente não
faz nada sozinho nessa vida é eu devo
muito isso a você você é um cara
especial
é então não trazer uma empresa que eu
queria que fosse especial para todo
mundo
as pessoas que trabalham pra mim quem
quer noutras me enriquece em todos os
aspectos financeiro é e emocional também
de realização seguinte
toda vez que a gente está indo no
caminho não toda vez mas muitas vezes eu
já vi isso acontecer muitas vezes a
gente acaba se desviando e quando você
se desvia do seu caminho você acaba
dimensionando os problemas de uma
maneira que acabam valor problema de que
ele não tem é você prioriza coisas em
detrimento de outras
e aí o que pode ser muito na sua vida
passa deixa de ser é eu tinha um
propósito o treinador traz na verdade
eram quatro
o primeiro era ter liberdade financeira
para fazer o que eu quisesse fazer o que
eu quisesse para conforto para a minha
família pra eu ter conforto para poder
fazer o que eu quisesse é o segundo era
poder desfrutar minha família sou casado
com a sabrina que está aqui tem três
filhas é eu sou um excelente
administrador por natureza o homem que
tem três filhas por natureza ganha
direito de pedir música no fantástico
que o seguinte se não empobrecer é
porque realmente sabe administrar as
contas então eu tenho três filhas eu
casar com essa mulher que escolhi pra
mim eu tomei a decisão de casar com ela
o meu quarto propõe não é o meu terceiro
proposta era ter prazer no meu trabalho
e 14 poder ajudar as pessoas
eu queria ajudar as pessoas acontece que
quando você não está bem o suficiente
com você mesmo quando esses indivíduos
seus propósitos
você não tem a menor condição de
modificar a vida de quem quer que seja
a gente fala muito hoje a gente vem é é
bonito dizer ah eu quero modificar o
mundo
quero deixar um traço lula eu quero é
mexer com a vida das pessoas mas é tem
um uma mudança precisa acontecer é que
mudança é interna é nessa nossa que se
ele não fizer manda na área eu passei
alguns anos mais precisamente quatro
anos da minha vida é e álvaro aliás o
álvaro que na rua esse passeio de
bicicleta por você está aqui ele é meu
amigo ele acha que porque ele não
enxerga quem ajuda a eles ou eu olha que
loucura esse cara é um dos meus maiores
amigos é um dos 11 conselheiros amado
que eu tenho um carinho enorme por ele
pessoa incrível é que quando eu estava e
aí eu pedi perdão a palavra porque eu
vou falar o seguinte durante quatro anos
houve 27 notei completamente
desorientado perdido e era enlouquecedor
pra mim porque é o seguinte tudo que eu
queria conseguir eu fiquei rico em um
pouco tempo me perdoem arrogância mas o
que aconteceu minha vida boa é eu
consigo trabalhar porque eu quero eu
tenho uma família que eu quero mas eu
nunca estava inteiro com a minha família
não tava ali então eu estava mas eu
nunca tava só que é o seguinte o que o
filho falou aqui é é importante pra mim
eu comungo dos mesmos 22 mesmas idéias
que o seguinte ninguém vive sem
princípios e valores
se você está perdido em algum momento
você recorre aos seus princípios e seus
valores
a minha base da minha mãe que está ali
você vai pra lugar nenhum quando se
recorre a eles você volta e você se
encontra
e aí é bom porque a tua vida começa a
andar foi quando eu criei projeto
pedaleiros
pedaleiros ele é simples ele é a criação
de pontos pela cidade com bicicletas no
formato também nós vamos habilitar
pessoas que são os nossos pedaleiros a
levar cegos e deficientes visuais
severos a passearem de bicicleta em
pontos onde seja possível pedalar
ai gente fantástica o indescritível
branco direito a áudio-descrição então
esperava mas dava tanta do sol pelo
corpo sensação de liberdade o vento no
rosto
não há nada como uma bicicleta ea
confiança que você pega outra pessoa que
está pedalando bem legal ótimo explicar
porque eu estava com muito medo depois
que eu fui
perdi o medo foi muito gostoso tudo que
pode trazer né a movimentação do que
pode trazer lazer tudo que pode aumentar
e melhorar os da saúde das pessoas é um
trabalho que é um dos cegos ela tem
compromisso com isso ele é um projeto de
amor
ele é um projeto de afeto um projeto que
a gente desenvolveu com a necessidade
que a gente sente de olhar para o lado e
de tentar fazer a vida das pessoas
melhor nessa bicicleta dupla anda
adultos e crianças faz o pessoal quer
cerro adquirir confiança pois é o
estéreo projeto porque ele é um projecto
maneiro
então agradeço a galera que o
responsável pelo pedaleiro vocês
acabaram de ver o primeiro projeto foi a
primeira vez que levou alguém com
deficiência visual para andar de
bicicleta mas foi incrível
ali o seguinte se eu não gostasse está
pedindo projeto acabava ali mas eles
gostaram e de lá pra cá faz quatro anos
que foi exatamente quando eu mudei a
minha vida a gente já fez várias etapas
no brasil a gente atingiu são paulo
diversas cidades aqui a gente levou mais
de duas mil pessoas para andar de
bicicleta é uma grande plataforma de
entretenimento da pessoa com deficiência
visual já levou jovens idosos adultos
gente de todo tipo de gente de todo
jeito e ele é um projeto feito pra
algumas pessoas bom
num primeiro lugar perfeito para as
pessoas que não enxergam e aí vêm os
recados objetivos do pedaleiros que eu
acho que às vezes eles acabam importando
mais do que as pedaladas
a pessoa que não enxerga os pedaleiros é
a quebra de paradigma e uva itália ele
pode corrigir o cego ou a pessoa que tem
uma deficiência visual muito severa ele
por natureza acredita que não há mais
nada na vida dele está condenado a
trancado em casa porque não enxerga ou
se ele não enxerga em tese ele não
precisa ver a luz é ele precisa pegar
sol e não fazer nada é então você não
pode fazer isso e também para namorar
não pode sair ele não pode trabalhar
para fazer nada que esse cara tem
utilizado é então ele é um hipertenso
por natureza é verdade assim a
hipertensão uma doença natural do cego é
muito em função do aspecto psicológico
do cérebro são dados do instituto
benjamin constant que diz o seguinte
como escreve com o sistema de defesa
dele ligado nessa sociedade é barulhenta
e que tem muita gente boa mas que dá
pouca atenção para esse tipo de pessoa é
escreve perdido no meio de um barulho
não termina
então como 12 chega pra eles falassem
liga quer dar uma volta de bicicleta
a reação não é das melhores eu diria é é
assim eu escutei algumas coisas que eu
não gostaria de te escutar lá sabe que
estou maluco é cego é você
coisas assim mas quando você banca idéia
e chama ele convence o cargo subir na
bicicleta ela não vai pedalar você vai
viver uma experiência diferente só que
acontece a gente transforma a vida dele
e aí o que acontece
ele é tão inteligente que ele por
analogia ver que o seguinte ele está
fazendo que é impossível que andar de
bicicleta então ele pode fazer qualquer
coisa que quiser e ao longo destes
quatro anos eu vi gente se empregar eu
vi gente arrumar namorado marido eu vi
gente feito álvaro virar professor de
capoeira professor de dança de salão e
empregar e palestrante é uma coisa de
louco mas isso acontece o 2º público
para quem a gente fala é pra gente
são pessoas como nós que vivemos agora a
experiência de pedalar com os olhos
vendados
na verdade aqui a pessoa que enxerga tem
duas oportunidades a primeira é
relativizar seus próprios problemas
se tem alguém que é cego
por mais que o problema seja muito grave
vamos combinar não dá para ser tão
grande
enquanto que o cara tem é quando a gente
começa a minimizar os problemas que a
gente tem os problemas que a gente tem
na vida a gente sempre fica
quando a gente dimensiona errado um
problema é acontece na nossa vida que
aconteceu comigo lá atrás quando eu
desviei do meu caminho do meu propósito
você começa a ir mal em si é muito bem
profissionalmente você vai mal
emocionalmente esse é o desequilíbrio a
vida inteira isso é ruim não é pra isso
que a gente vive
então essa é a primeira por treinado na
segunda oportunidade de viver na pele a
experiência do outro é de sentir
exatamente como um cego de vive andando
sendo guiado com os olhos vendados numa
pedra numa bicicleta é a cujo passeio é
de escrito para que a pessoa tenha todas
as sensações
agora esse passeio vendado efeito ou
pessoas que enxergam ele ele revela
muito da gente na maneira como a gente
vive porque eu nunca sugerir que as
pessoas gostassem do projeto do do
passeio com os olhos vendados na verdade
eu queria que elas vivem a experiência
às vezes a experiência boa muitas vezes
é mas muitas vezes ela também não é só
porque porque a gente tem a mania de
achar que a gente consegue controlar
tudo na vida
quando você sobe numa bicicleta do
pedaleiros quem está na frente guia e
quem está atrás guiado a pedalada
acontece junto mas você não tem controle
nenhum sobre está acontecendo e é
diferente da vida que ele viveu a gente
em controle sobre todas as variáveis
numa empresa a gente controla e domina
perfeitamente todas as variáveis que a
gente conhece o que a gente desconhece
não é assim que funciona na vida e aí
tem uma coisa grave eu nunca faço juízo
de valor sobre o que é bom o que é ruim
para as pessoas mas nesse caso
específico oportunidade que espera perde
de se colocar em contato consigo mesmo
por 15 minutos que sejam a visão física
ela provoca o negócio a gente é o nosso
louco ela traz com ela todos os
preconceitos que existem é e traz com
ela todas as barreiras que bloqueia a
gente de fazer tudo o que a gente quer
e assim eu sei que tem gente muito bem
preparado aqui a questão é
sua feta a toda a humanidade em todos os
níveis é se você não tira da tua frente
às barreiras mentais que nascem e entrou
através dos teus olhos físicos
amigo é acertar fadado a ter problema da
tua vida
essa oportunidade não se pode perder a
segunda o terceiro público na verdade é
o cara que tem a nossa bala de prata é
um pedaleiro guia a quem eu agradeço do
fundo do meu coração porque eu amo essas
pessoas são pessoas abnegadas assim é um
pedaleiro guia é um exemplo cabal de que
a humanidade tem jeito sim de que tem
muito mais gente boa do que gente ruim e
tem muita gente a fim de ajudar os
outros e fazer o bem de colaborar e
compartilhar de fazer com qualidade de
fazer com amor de fazer com excelência é
esse cara é o responsável por levar a
nossa pessoa com deficiência visual para
passear
eu tenho uma chance de transformar a
vida desse cara
se a experiência desse cara não for
única
se ele não voltar do passeio de
bicicleta excepto pedaleiro guia que ele
foi voar como a obra sugeriu fazer com
vocês
ao invés de fugir pela lá porque é assim
que a gente fala eu perdi a chance de
salvar as caras
graças a deus os nossos pedalinhos são
pessoas treinadas
a gente prepara elas a gente seleciona o
perfil das casas fazem teste
psicotécnico teste psicológico é a tess
prático mas assim a gente escolhe gente
que pedala um dois três dias seguidos
quatro cinco seis sete horas debaixo de
sol e sai dali feliz porque fez o bem
sai dali feliz porque fazer o bem faz
também que a gente não consegue nem
acreditar que aquilo está acontecendo
bom aí chegou a hora da minha
transformação num
vocês viram a eu criei um projeto de
liberdade ela não traz uma empresa que
eu queria trabalhar
o amor da minha vida que eu coloco todo
meu esforço
coloco dedicação coloco tempo e gera
resultado financeiro gera resultado
emocional pra mim para as pessoas que
trabalham comigo não está com os
satisfaz é essa é uma coisa aí eu
desviei por algum momento do meu caminho
e pra longe do meu propósito mas eu
voltei com pedaleiros e chegou a minha
hora
olha só eu coloquei muita dedicação
nesse projeto muita muito amor
coloquei recurso financeiro conhecimento
técnico tudo que aprendi na outra eu
apliquei no pedaleiros conhecimento
comunicação de produção de tecnologia de
criação eu queria transformar um
pedaleiro de uma plataforma global de
entretenimento para pessoas com
deficiência visual é isso o que ele é
já foi a nova iorque conversar com gente
que cuida do departamento de deficientes
visuais
lá no central park está encantado com
esse negócio é levar para lá mas nunca
lá só pra lá eu preciso levar pro
salvador
é preciso levar preparado precisava para
rondônia é preciso levar pro rio grande
do sul
pedalei com pouca gente ainda não
cumprir minha missão
mas a gente fez isso porque a gente
queria realmente criar alguma coisa que
mexeu com a vida das pessoas de verdade
eu queria tocar o coração das pessoas de
verdade e eu precisava dar sentido na
minha vida eu amo trabalhar mas a
nocividade do trabalho às vezes não me
faz tão bem então a gente tem que achar
o caminho em que o equilíbrio existe a
minha vida começou a transformar na hora
que eu decidi olhar para ela com os
olhos que eu queria e eu tomei a decisão
de olhar para a vida com bons olhos
acho ótimo acho incrível vida é boa
demais
tem muita gente boa
tem muita gente legal olha o que esse
cara será pó
o reitor com essa idade eu sou um fã
apaixonado pela obra pó pra essa família
inteira gente boa
preocupada ela tem a melhor faculdade
brasil tem a melhor faculdade brasil
casa dele e da família
é isso que eu queria fazer com amor
fazer com verdade com carinho em
liberdade
então eu queria liberdade
só que a liberdade ela só vem na nossa
vida
quando a gente faz na nossa gente
escutar a gente escuta o nosso coração
não você não escuta o coração a
liberdade não vem e se você não está
liberto e não faz nada na sua vida está
aprisionado sem liberdade ninguém faz
nada
um passarinho na gaiola não voa a minha
vida transformou porque eu queria ser
exemplo para as minhas filhas eu queria
ser um orgulho pra minha mãe orgulho
para minha mulher cresceu orgulho e
exemplo para as pessoas que trabalham
com o meu eu queria isso queria isso
desejo lhes chama o legado deixar uma
marca de verdade mas também para fazer
isso é inteiro a íntegro tem que ser de
verdade tem que ser autêntico era isso
que eu queria para a minha vida a minha
vida mudou quando eu fui na minha
você vai na sua vaga na sua estreia
[Música]
[Aplausos]